[Music]
good afternoon my name is Dominic price
I'm the product lead for our database
products on Google cloud platform
welcome to cloud spanner 201 very
excited to have Peter Beckham here from
Quizlet to also talk about his
experience with cloud spanner
recession I like to set goals if this
isn't what you came here for feel free
to go to another session I won't be
offended we're going to talk about how
to set up your cloud spanner schema
we're going to talk about how to
optimize your queries and then we're
going to get lessons from Peter about
how to migrate in implement a
application or cloud spanner just quick
show of hands how many people were at
the spanner 101 session alright good
I'll do a quick overview of cloud
spanner before we dive in
so summarizing from the cloudspinner 101
and for all of those of you who have
come to the COTS banner booth what is
cloud spanner
so cloud spanner it's Google's
mission-critical scalable relational
database service what this means is that
you get a relational database with acid
semantics and transactional consistency
with horizontal scalability so you get
the horizontal scalability of a no
sequel system with the transactional
semantics and sequel semantics that you
come to expect from your traditional are
two VMs cloud spanner is a fully managed
database service with global scale
traditional relational semantics so you
get schemas acid transactions sequel we
do automatic synchronous replication
within and across regions and it's been
battle tested inside of Google and the
101 session I went through how our last
manually restart and my sequel took
several years and led to us to build
cloud spanner where it's been in
production at Google behind most of our
mission-critical applications for the
last nine plus years fimA design so one
of the things that's really interesting
about cloud spanner is when we did the
demo at the keynote today and you saw
the application you don't really have
many levers when you create a cloud
spanner instance you give us a name you
tell us what the topology is you want
regional and it later this year we'll
have multi regional and you tell us the
number of nodes that you want you don't
pre provision storage you don't tell us
anything about your data you just tell
us the number of nodes and so 100% of
your levers for optimizing your
performance on spanner are your schema
and your queries so similar to cloud
BigTable your schema design is
incredibly important to in determining
the performance that your application is
going to get when you deploy it
let's start with the basics so people
ask me I've gotten my sequel database
I've got a post Chris database how do I
migrate so the first thing is your
schema cloud spanner supports the most
common sequel data types so boolean's
integers floats strings bytes arrays
dates and timestamps I've put it up
against my sequel so you can see we
support all of the similar ones except
mice people doesn't support arrays and
then obviously my sequel and Postgres
have lots of other data types things
like JSON and other features that we
haven't implemented yet in cloud spanner
the key thing here is that anything that
you see anything that you have in your
my sequel or your post Escrima should be
directly transferable into cloud spanner
the first thing you have to be very
aware of in cloud spanner when building
your schemas is interleave tables so my
sequel doesn't have a concept of child
tables
Postgres does have child tables but
they're for a different purpose
interleave tables in spanner is the way
that you can tell cloud spanner the
logical relationship of your data and
this allows us to serve your data more
effectively and efficiently so the way
to think of an interleave table is if
you have a row in this case singers and
all of your other data is related to
that in this case albums and songs you
want them all join together so think of
an inner leaf table as a precomputed
join on your data to allow your queries
to be really efficient what happens here
is that when we are querying your data
so if you say give me all the songs for
a specific singer if you have those
interleaved then we can very quickly and
efficiently return those results to you
because we know that all the data is
related and so we'll make best efforts
to make sure that all of that data is
located on the same node and very
physically close to its related data so
we can return it as quickly as possible
and hopefully avoid two-phase commits
when we do transactions so by telling us
that these this thing is related to this
other thing which we call data locality
we can actually start to do a much
better job of serving your data
the other thing that's important about
interleave tables is that cloud spanner
does not support the concept of foreign
key constraints our version of foreign
key constraints are these interleaf
tables so if you need cascade on delete
between items then interleave tables is
the way that you achieve this so if you
want to do cascade on delete for a
object or for a row it's a pretty good
signal to you that you should probably
interleave it with its parents
but what does this look like in a schema
again cloud spanner uses standard sequel
for schemas and for queries so as you're
doing your DD owls and defining your
schema you would this is what it would
look like so create tables singers I
have an integer field for the singer ID
I've got a string for first name a
string for last name and a byte field
for singer info where the primary key is
singer ID now albums always are tied to
a singer so therefore I can put a album
ID and an album title set the primary
keys so on an inner leaf table pile
tables have to include the primary keys
of the parent right this is how we
literally do the interleaving on the
physic the physical interleaving of the
data in the database so my primary key
has to include singer ID because of the
parent and then I can say inner Levon
parent singers on delete cascade so this
is how I implement a foreign key
constraint in terms of Cascade on delete
but it's also how I do a pre-computer
join between singers and albums now to
go another layer songs always belong to
an album so now I can say create table
songs we can add a track ID and a song
name the primary key has to include the
primary keys of the two previous tables
so singer ID and album ID and now we can
add track ID as a primary key so I
interleave in parent albums for on
delete so as you're building your
schemas this is how you tell spanner
what is the logical relationship of your
data in the schema
I talked a little bit about primary keys
spanner is different than some of the
relational databases we don't have auto
increment IDs it's very important that
we have distribution of primary keys so
it's very important that you don't do
sequential keys specifically not time
stamps we recommend that you use
real-world identifiers because this
generally gives us sufficient amount of
randomization to shard your data between
the nodes and as we talked about before
it defines the physical relationship of
the data so the primary keys are the way
that we know that one thing relates to
another
the next concept that every good our
DBMS has is secondary indexes so I've
built my schema I've run some queries
and I see that they're slow how can I
speed up those speed up those queries
one way that I can speed up the query is
by adding indexes so spanner allows you
to build secondary indexes so in this
case we've got a table that has
marketing budget which is an integer
we've defined the primary keys in the
parent table and now we've added a
function in our DDL that says create
index albums by album title on albums
where the key is album title so this
allows us to are on the column album
title so what does it does is allows us
to more efficiently query the table
albums without having to do a table scan
of the entire primary table pretty
straightforward
interleave indexes allow you to
co-locate your index with your data so
again if you are always doing queries
inside of a certain key space so in this
particular time if you're always
searching for all the things for a
singer right I want to know every song
that Prince ever did I want to know
every song that's on an album I want to
know you know if we have number of
records sold I want to do I want to
aggregate all of the records sold for
prints over a period of time I can
co-locate the index with the physical
data to further increase performance by
interleaving that table in the parent
table so I can say create index songs by
singer album songs on this table provide
the columns that I want and interleave
it in tables so now when I do that query
there's no chance that my index which is
just a normal table and spanner doesn't
get located on another node right so the
way to think about this is if I build a
secondary index and I don't tell spanner
cloud spanner that it's interleaved what
could happen is the primary table could
be on one node and the index table could
be on another node and now every time I
want to update the primary table I have
to coordinate between the two of them
and do a two-phase commit similarly if I
want to do a transient read I have to
access both nodes to get the data but if
I tell cloud spanner that this data is
related by interleaving it then I can
always go to a single node and I don't
have to incur the overhead of going to
multiple nodes
let's talk about some anti patterns so I
talked a little bit about this earlier
but I wanted to reiterate the point
because it's a common problem that we
see as you're loading data in the cloud
spanner we if there's a natural
inclination to use ink time stamps or
values that will incremental e increase
as you go through the system and what
happens here is because you're
constantly adding keys that are further
along you're forcing all of the rights
onto a single cloud spanner server and
so what happens is that you can hotspot
the server because you're always trying
to add another value at the end of the
row
short ID either by taking a couple
values off the hash or just adding a
random shard what that allows us to do
and then and then putting that in the
primary key first what that allows us to
do is to evenly distribute the rights
across all the span servers so by giving
us a more diverse key space you allow us
to better shard the data across the
nodes and that allows us to more
effectively write data into the system
one of the things that's in here is is
split points so we we do our very best
never to split between primary keys in
the root table which is the first table
at the top of the interleave and so the
more values you give us of primary keys
at the root table the more places we
have to put splits and because you've
told us that this data is an interleaved
we know that we can split it up up up
across multiple nodes and that'll be
fine if you do interleave it then we
know that we need to keep it together
and that gives us again a better hint of
how to logically lay out your data in
the database
and so where this is most important as
data loading so one of the challenges is
making sure that you're loading your
data in a efficient way so one is
partitioning your data by primary key so
using the best practice we talked about
either invert your timestamps or put a
hash or create a shard ID in front of
your timestamps or moving the timestamp
to the second or third primary key is a
way to make sure that we can partition
your data efficiently and load your data
in the most efficient way we also
recommend that you batch your commits
into one to five megabyte mutations at a
time
so you can do multiple writes in a
single transaction we recommend about
one to five megabytes of data on each
transaction and the last thing is create
your table and your schema load your
data and then add your indexes it's much
faster to load your data and that allow
us to backfill a secondary index than it
is for us to do multiple writes on every
insert by making sure that we've
inserted data into the primary table and
the index on every write so always add
your indexes at the end if you're doing
a large data load job as you saw in the
keynote demo that we did today we did an
80 terabyte database of ticket
information and as we were loading the
data we were able to dramatically
increase the load time by patching up
the mutations and making sure that we
had a very diverse key space and it
really does impact your ability to load
data into the system if you break any of
these best practices
very optimization so you have all the
basic pieces of schema design you
understand what the gotchas are so now
you can start to look at your queries
first of all cloud sequel speaks sequel
for its schema definition and for its
querying when you're doing mutations we
provide a separate API for doing
mutations so that you can be more
explicit to us about what you want us to
do with your data but as you do your
queries there's a number of ways that
you can have slow queries or want to
speed up your queries so the first one
is missing an index so I want to select
last name first name from Singers where
the last name equals Smith now the issue
here is that I'm not searching on index
data so I'm doing a full table scan so
if I want to avoid doing that I can
create an index Singers by last name on
Singers an index last name so this will
allow me to more efficiently query the
table and remove and pull back that
information now I can actually make this
faster if I go ahead and do this prior
to this first query select last name
first name or last name equals Smith I
will find the row based on last name but
I still have to go back to the primary
table to get the first name so I still
have to join back to the primary table
after I find the key so the way that you
can optimize this in cloud spanner is
using the storing function so you can
say create index Singers by last name on
singers last name storing first-name so
what I've done is I've added additional
information to the index so that I can
retrieve data by directly reading the
index table and never having to go back
to the primary table so again another
way to alleviate the need to go back and
do effectively a join back to the
primary table
missing indexes for ordered results so
if you were doing lots of selects and
you are doing order by you want to make
sure that you have an index that's a
properly built for that so if you're
saying select first name last name from
Singers order by last name first name
descending then you want to make sure
that you have created and ended in index
so singers by last name on singers last
name first name in descending and the
way that you figure all this out we we
very quickly showed in the keynote today
how to look at your queries and so when
you run a query in the cloud console
there's a button there that says explain
query and it will show you what we're
actually doing in the query and so these
things will become apparent to you as
you look at the the query plan to
understand whether or not you're
effectively using your indexes
so what if I'm not using my indexes or
what if I'm trying to do different kinds
of joins so a number of people have come
up to me today at the spanner booth and
said do you support joins and I say yes
and they say which joins and so we do
support a number of joins so inner
crosse full left and right we do these
are all again additional vectors for you
to help optimize how you're recording
your data but we do provide a number of
options for you that you would expect
from a traditional art of EMS the other
thing that we do is join directives so
we often talked about how cloud spanner
uses an SI sequel 2011 with extensions
the two main extensions that we have are
interleave so for interleave tables and
our annotations and one of the most
common annotations is a join directive
so you can see in this first query
select start from singers join and then
this at bracket annotation is what we
use across sequel in spanner to do
annotations instead of doing a my sequel
keyword for this we wanted to have a
single semantics for doing these hints
not just for joins but across the data
and so this is the annotation extension
that we've added to sequel one of the
things that's interesting about spanner
and is different than a traditional are
to be a mess is that spanner doesn't try
to assume too much about your data it
doesn't try to figure out the best
possible way to to run your query we
have a query optimizer and if there's a
obvious index for us to use then we'll
use it but in many scenarios spanner
will not choose to use the index that
you might have intended and so spanner
is just is designed to be very explicit
about what you want to do and so one of
these is indexes so when you run this
query if you look on the query explained
and you notice that you aren't hitting
your join then what you can do is use
the second query so select singer first
name last name singer info from singers
at force index equals and you can tell
us the index so if you look at your
query explain plan and you realize that
you aren't hitting the index you can add
this annotation
you're joining to force the query to use
your index and the last one is we also
have additional hash joint or sorry join
types so here we've got a hash join
there loop joins as well and all of this
is in the sequel documentation but we do
provide all of these as ways for you to
optimize again cloud spanner the only
knob you get is nodes so all of these
tools that we have in the schema and in
the query are your tools to optimize
your your queries and optimize your
performance all right with that I'm
gonna bring up Peter bottom enough of
the information about spanner I'm sure
all of you want to get some practical
information about what it really means
to you spanner so I bring up Peter
everybody I'm Peter I work on a platform
at Quizlet and I'm gonna be talking to
you today about what it's like to use a
spanner from a customer's perspective
and some of the results of our testing
we were really really fortunate to get
early access to spanner and we've been
playing around with it so my goal here
is to give you a really good picture of
what we've learned and hopefully come
away from this talk with a better idea
of how you might use spanner yourself
your own workloads as I said we've been
testing for a while I'm gonna show you
some of the test results we hope to run
spanner in production for one of our
tables very very soon and we'll have
more information then but I'm gonna get
a view a lead picture of what we know so
I want to start by giving you just a
brief introduction to us and Quizlet
Quizlet is an EdTech company or a study
tool the product is you you plug in
terms and definitions and it gives you
different ways to study them so you can
think of it as like a digital flashcard
that kind of thing
Quizlet we've been really lucky to have
strong organic growth and so Quizlet
over time has grown into a top 25
website in the u.s. we have about 25
million users a month
and a bunch of different study modes web
clients made mobile native clients etc
our growth curve over time has looked
like this as I said we've had really
we've had been have really strong
organic growth and this is an
interesting challenge for databases for
several reasons so one is that you'll
note that it's very very seasonal right
it turns out no one really studies in
the summer so we get this big drop in
the summer that's pretty quiet and then
around August September we hit back to
school and so there we get this big big
rush and as we go up that's also where a
lot of our growth hits so in the summer
we have to do this preparation we need
to prepare for this traffic that we've
never really seen before
so very very seasonal but also the
traffic is gradually increasing it's
always going up and so what this means
is that we've had to continually
reaaargh attacked Andry figure out how
to run our application was it runs my
sequel like many applications we started
just with a simple web app using my
sequel and over time we've had to
optimize this and grow this into a more
complex architecture our architecture
now looks a little bit like this so let
me explain this a little bit we started
with just a simple database we added
replicas so that you could failover from
the master to replicas if you needed to
we can also swap back and forth for
maintenance we've added replicas for
backups and then one of the ways we've
scaled is by taking some of our tables
and splitting them out into their own
pods of master and replicas so this is
basically vertical sharding right we've
taken a table we're running it
separately
and we scale up this way so you know
this has grown some of it we have about
eight pods of this in production right
now you can see on this diagram some of
the pods have multiple replicas we also
have a tier of caching to help scale so
I think this is a fairly standard
architecture and I'm sure that many
people in this room have have something
similar maybe even with a greater scale
several problems with this so one is
just complexity right there's a lot of
lines up here it's a complex
architecture we need to run it we need
to handle replication backups etc
failover etc so you know maintenance
costs difficulty but the other problem
is just scalability right so we haven't
done any horizontal sharding this means
that a single tables only is running
accepting writes at most on a single
machine so this is a pretty fundamental
barrier for us right we can only handle
so many writes on a single machine this
means we're limited in how big we can
let a table grow so what's the next
phase this is really really critical for
Quizlet this is is the primary data
store so everything depends on this and
in fact if this goes down we literally
we have students complaining to us we
have people tweeting at us people in
classrooms come to a halt this is what
this looks like
so if quizlets database goes down we get
tweets like this it's literally a
classroom of students it's hard to see
but they're all holding up iPads that
say Quizlet is down on them and so I
show this just to underline the point
that database stability and scalability
is like really really critical for us
it's it's a study product it's very high
engagement when you use it and so it's
really important that the data base be
stable and performance and it grows over
time so we want to solve this problem
we've been examining spanner to do that
and I want to talk to you next about how
we help we looked at this and how we
evaluate whether spanner would be a good
match for this workload
we do this well first thing we did is we
picked a table that we were having
trouble scaling so first table we picked
is called the terms table it's about 700
gigabytes
6 billion rows and this is the core
content of quiz mode so it's really
important table for us suitable scale
receives it's about 70% reads 30% writes
so fairly significant write load so we
took this table we observed how it
looked in production so the the queries
coming in did a capture of those looked
in depth at the patterns etc and then we
created a synthetic workload based on
that capture so what I mean by that is
we wrote a script to generate queries in
a similar pattern as the the captured
queries so same ratio of reads and
writes same query patterns same locality
of IDs etc as close as we could make it
look so that we had the synthetic
workload and then we're able to play
this against both spanner in our test
environment and against a separate test
my sequel and this is interesting
because it gives us you know a really
clean environment for comparing these
two systems and doing results so let me
caveat this by saying this is like
obviously very very specific to our use
case and the results you're going to see
are totally totally specific to your
workload and may look different in other
cases but I want to show you what this
looks like for us first question I have
is how do these databases scale so how
do we answer this well what we've done
is we've taken our synthetic workload
we've played it against both systems and
we've observed query latency as we
changed out of the throughput so x axis
here is throughput y axis is y axis is
latency as you can see my sequel latency
initially lower than spanner so this is
around one millisecond
during normal conditions we then as you
can expect you eventually hit your
performance
sealing and so we hit a threshold at
which we really can't handle more
queries we see a spike in latency for my
sequel here
spanner we have a higher base latency
and obviously you also cap out at a
certain point but the key point here is
it's really really easy to just change
the number of nodes and scale the span
or cluster and move your performance
ceiling higher so this is the whole
point right this is this is why is this
a powerful system so this is median
latency and the other thing we wanted to
look at is tail latency so what you're
looking at here is 99th percentile
latency on this workload that we ran so
again we're comparing these two systems
we're running spanner at different sizes
and you can see as you approach your
threshold tail latency goes up in this
curve right an interesting thing here
also is that the spanner tail latency or
the my sequel tail line see it's
actually worse than spanner for the low
query thresholds so again this is
totally specific to us and specific to
the my sequel instance we were running
but our goal here was to test the
scalability of spanner and how a
synthetic workload would look on the two
systems it was I think it was a
successful strategy so I want to dig a
little bit more into this latency
because I think it's really important if
you're using spanner and implementing
into an application so what I'm going to
show you now is a histogram of spanner
latency in this workload so this is
spanner latency for one of the easier
queries we're running the x-axis here is
is buckets of latency and the y-axis is
count so this query on spanner we saw
five milliseconds median latency and
this is the curve we saw so we see an
initial jump in the curve and then we
see you know a longer tailed latency but
as I noted before the the long tail was
fairly thin so for to us spanner was
surprisingly consistent and it's
right so this is great we know about the
latency we know a little bit about the
scalability I want to talk more about
what are the implications of spanner for
our application and one of the other
things we want to know about the other
several things so one as I noted with
spanner compared to my sequel just
running out of vanilla VM probably your
base latency is going to be a little bit
higher your tail latency is probably
going to be lower for us a higher base
latency needs we need to be more
thoughtful about how we use it in the
application so asynchronous queries
become a little more important and the
other thing is that it's very very
scalable so again this is this is the
thing we really like about spanner this
is the power that we can just change the
number of nodes and adjust the
performance ceiling of the database so
what this means is it for your
application auto scaling becomes really
really simple you're basically just
changing a variable the other thing we
noted spanner is a distributed system as
you may know it partitions your data and
disciplines and this has implications on
your schema on your IDs etc as Dom
mentioned the other interesting thing we
we observed so as we were running the
synthetic workload we ran it on both
systems both as you can imagine you
initially start sending the queries you
see warming right both systems warm up
you see the initial spike and then a
little bit flatter cloudspinner
interestingly also optimizes the splits
and so over time we saw a more gradual
warming on spanner
so as we ran a certain cluster size the
latency would actually get better over
time so we have a good idea now of
spanner performance scalability some of
the implications of integrating with our
app and I want to talk a little bit more
about what this looks like for us in
other words how we integrate it so
several things here
first thing is we need a way to talk to
spanner so we need to pick a client
Quizlet was originally written in PHP we
now run on h hv m which is facebook's
PHP compiler and our code is a mix of
PHP and hack PHP is is the favorite
language of few people and so we've
optimized and we really like h hv m and
hack and it's been a good way to carry
application forward so there's not yet a
spanner PHP client though I understand
one is coming soon
so initial options for for the client
are one
there's the REST API this is just
totally generic sending HTTP and getting
responses back but to one of the things
that I really like about spanner is that
it sits behind the G RPC interface so
because it's gr PC the interface is fine
totally programmatically and it's
actually possible to generate clients in
any language that your procedure
supports so we've actually used both of
these strategies from application next
thing for us is how do we take our
application and actually great queries
to send this banner and send them so
like many applications we use an ORM
ours is custom to us I've put an example
query here the point is that the
application you're composing a query
using this fluent interface you're
setting some some parameters maybe some
query predicates etc then you're going
and generating sequel so integration for
us looks like taking this interface and
re-implementing the backend a
specifically first banner so the sequel
dialect is a little bit different than
my sequel and spanner doesn't offer DML
statements so that's a little bit
different but in general it's very
similar and this is the whole point
right
we want something relational we can we
can move to so we've taken this ORM
interface and we've reimplemented for
spanner and so within our app we're now
able to communicate with both systems
using the same fluent interface so this
is our strategy for handling this
you
so I want to talk a little bit more
about schema for our case as Dom meant
it might as Don mentioned there's some
definite schema implications for spanner
you know the nice part is that much of
our schema maps directly over again this
is the whole point we want to move to a
system where we have the relational
model our data types carry over our
queries carry over and it's more
scalable so most things are not directly
over there's a few implications for the
ID format I'm gonna dive into that and
then the other important thing to
remember is just you want your schema to
be thoughtful around data locality so
you want to use your schema to limit the
number of queries that touch multiple
splits in other words that touch a bunch
of areas of your data and I'll show you
how we do this so I'm gonna show you our
schema on my sequel and then our schema
on spanner there's a lot of details I'm
gonna highlight the important parts of
this it's mostly pretty similar right
we've taken a we've taken our columns
we've mapped them over we've mapped them
into Spanish data types the things I'm
going to call it here are one we've
added new ID columns so we've added
columns specific to two spanners ID ID
ID sorry specific to spanners favorable
primary key characteristics we've
changed the primary key and we've
intentionally used a primary key that
gives us locality on that column spanner
ID
so the spanner ID column there's
locality within the spanner set ID and
we've designed the primary key that way
we've also leveraged the secondary index
here and so we're creating that in the
schema as well so let me explain a
little bit more about how we're handling
IDs so as dom
spanner does not have auto incrementing
IDs and even if it did you probably
wouldn't want to use them you know the
reason is that you want to distribute
your rights over multiple splits and so
it's much more favorable to use
something with a lot of entropy in the
first few bits so there's different ways
to slice this our choice was v4 UUID and
this is basically just randomly
generated UUID there's other UUID
formats like v1 that aren't favorable
for this and the reason is that they can
include a time component in the very
beginning so you're not evenly
distributing your rights so we don't
store any meeting in the IDS so we're
just using randomly generated IDs
the other interesting thing in our case
is that backwards compatibility with
previous IDs is very important to us so
as I mentioned Quizlet has a native of
mobile clients all these native mobile
clients they depend on a certain version
of the API they access models with
certain assumptions like they have
integer IDs and actually cache data as
well so they're storing data and saving
that and so migrating to a new system
means supporting those clients because
their mobile clients we can't just
upgrade them all immediately right
they're out there in the wild so we very
explicitly left in our previous IDs and
we have a secondary index in our schema
for those IDs this is a little bit this
is a diagram of what this looks like we
have multiple versions of our API we've
planned a new version to support a new
ID scheme and we're going to be
migrating mobile clients over to this as
we go so one more thing I want to talk
about and that's how we move how we move
data into spanner so as I mentioned
uptime is very important to us stability
is very important to us and so we can't
just shut the site down for hours as we
prepare the new database and copy data
in so we want to be able to transition
over flip a switch and
be done so the way we think about this
is replicating data by establishing
rights to both systems so we take your
application we're using my sequel
reading and writing from my sequel my
Siegel is a source of truth
we're also duplicating rights to spanner
so we send rights there as well that
means mutations to our models go to both
systems while that's happening we then
run a copy client in the background a
copies data over into spanner and
eventually you end up with a very
consistent data set
this is a little tricky because only one
system could be the source of truth
right only one system can be the source
of truth and so if the right fails to
the other one you need to know that you
then have a data inconsistency so for us
this just means tracking those failed
rights and and ensuring that that both
systems are consistent so the whole
point of this is to transition over
easily so you begin writing to both
systems you do the copy in the
background you reach a point where
they're similar you stop rights and then
you can just flip over to the new system
this is our plan for for switching over
a table to spanner so that's all I've
prepared thanks for listening I hope
this was useful
[Music]
you